Tomorrow, the House will vote
to repeal Obamacare,
so if you're thinking
about getting
a life threatening illness
that could bankrupt
you and your family,
today's the day!
Republicans need 216 votes
and only have a margin of error
of 21 votes,
which is much smaller than the
3 million vote margin of error
they needed to win the election.
That is why Steve Bannon
sent his assistant,
thrice-married
Atlantic City casino magnate
and ex-Pizza Hut spokesman
Donald Trump,
to convince Republicans
to take health insurance away
from millions of people.
Also to golf
and, time permitting,
avoid his third wife.
Now, back in Mordor, D.C.,
House Speaker
and sociopath Mickey Mouse Club
member Paul Ryan
has been leading the effort
and enticing amendments
to the new health bill
to attract
more Republican votes,
because the thought
of kicking 14 million people
off their health insurance
just isn't doing it
for him anymore, you guys.
So, comedians,
what amendments can they add
to the American Health Care Act
to make it more attractive
to Republicans?
-(bell dings)
-Hari.
Health care is free
to anyone who agrees
to be a slave.
-Okay. All right.
-(laughter)
I'll give you points for that.
-(bell dings)
-Uh, Eugene.
Um, if you are a diagnosed
with an STD,
Paul Ryan pushes you
out a window.
-All right. Points.
-(laughter)
Points.
-(bell dings)
-Greg Proops.
Uh, some young boys
in an airport restroom?
-All right, points. Points.
-(laughter)